salut aujourd'hui choix grenoble en
tournée j'en profite pour vous faire une
nouvelle vidéo si vous avez suivi le
blog mensuel vous est rendu compte qu'au
mois de janvier j'étais en train
d'écrire un livre petite exclu j'ai la
date le livre sortira le 18 mai bam j'ai
balancé l'info est en ce moment je suis
sur un autre projet oui je suis derrière
et à chaque fois que je vous parle de ce
genre de choses vous ne demandez d'où
provient la stimulation la créativité et
bien c'est la réponse de ce hack life
[Musique]
la créativité tout le monde en à vous en
avez j'en ai mon régisseur en a on est
tous créatif
seulement il est intéressant d'avoir les
quelques clés pour pouvoir accéder à ce
processus là et aujourd'hui je vous
donne quelques conseils en vrac quand
vous êtes sur un projet quel qu'il soit
changer de point de vue un maximum de
fois c'est à dire que vous changez la
caméra de place dans mon spectacle
actuellement j'écris un passage sur pie
est en fait j'essaie de me mettre à la
place de pi à la place de ce nombre là
et puis après j'essaye de me mettre à la
place de ceux qui sont découverts pis et
puis je me mets à la place de ceux qui
potentiellement aurait créé pillon de
séparer sur une feuille de noter aussi
tout les jeux de mots les images sur
lesquelles m'envoyer pis pour vous dire
un moment donné j'ai même noter la ligne
3 la ligne 14 de paris parce que 3,14
fait un espèce de brainstorming seul en
changeant les points de vue en
permanence et surtout noté ce qui vous
vient
notez tout le temps noté toujours même
si vous trouvez ça débile et inutile
noter un des meilleur conseil que je
puisse vous donner aussi c'est de faire
ce que vous allez me revient vous
consommez culturellement quand c'est des
choses culturelles
si par exemple vous les faire la musique
fêtent la musique que vous aimeriez
entendre si vous écrivez un moment
écrivait le roman que vous aimeriez lire
sur le thème que vous aimeriez lire ne
cherchez pas ce qui fonctionne chercher
ce que vous aimez vous et en parlant de
livres c'est très bien d'acheter des
livres que vous ne lisez pas je sais
qu'un acte déjà pas mal qu'il le vont en
fait vous pouvez acheter des livres que
vous prévoyez de lire un moment donné
qui vous plaisent parce que là ils sont
là disponibles devant toute cette phrase
là c'est une citation d'un cinéaste qui
s'appelle john motors alors évidemment
faut pas prendre au pied de la lettre
mais l'idée finale c'est de pouvoir les
piocher dans cette source d'inspiration
après quand vous en avez besoin
la zone de confort non à d
j'ai parlé ici sur cette chaîne dernier
en 2016 cette vidéo sur la zone de
confort il est important essentiel de
sortir de sa zone de confort ce pour
pouvoir se stimuler tous fait des choses
que vous n'avez pas l'habitude de faire
aller travailler dans des endroits
inhabituels pour vous allez voir des
choses que vous n'avez pas l'habitude de
voir
ouvrez-vous autre chose et vous allez
voir c'est très stimulant si en
créativité ne passait jamais à côté
d'une idée cherché à creuser la moindre
idée qui vous vient prenez le temps de
ne rien faire également de rester dans
votre lit ou assis de réfléchir c'est
pas ne rien faire réfléchir il faut se
donner ce temps là pour le spectacle
chez en train de faire actuellement la
plupart des idées ne sont venus quand
j'étais en vacances au mexique l'année
dernière c'est-à-dire quand j'étais dans
une situation de ne rien faire dans les
choses qui marchent bien également c'est
d'utiliser des post it ou des papiers et
de noter plein d'idées de les poser et
les remixes et entraide et de voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe n'hésitez pas
à lancer des projets inachevés également
sur lesquels vont reviendrai plus tard
ça c'est quelque chose qui arrive
souvent que j'aime bien le carnet avec
la ddt de débuter et un jour quand tu en
as besoin tu peux retourner de temps et
puis je pense que le conseil final le
plus important que je peux donner en
tout cas dans ma méthodologie c'est de
ne pas avoir peur d'essayer de faire les
choses
essayez c'est pas grave si ce n'est pas
exactement ça ça se retourne il n'y a
pas un chef-d'oeuvre ou un super jeu ou
un super film moi un super jeu vidéo qui
n'a été fait du premier coup tout ça ça
se travaille donc n'hésitez pas à
aboutir les premiers jets pareil pour le
livre j'ai fait le premier jet en
janvier et maintenant je suis en train
de le retoucher
mais le fait de sortir au moins
entièrement un premier jet c'est quelque
chose de très aussi valorisant ça fait
du bien
et après ça vous donne du matos pour
travailler c'est une des questions
récurrentes qu'on me pose à la fin des
spectacles en tournée donc je me suis
dit ça valait le coup de vous en faire
une vidéo directement ac life ou life à
qui il y en a plein qui sont surpris que
j'appelle ces vidéos ac life et qui me
disent c'est pas ça qu'on dit en fait
c'est ça qu'on dit si je décide que
c'est ça que je dis parce que justement
ce sont pas des life ac mais des actes
life's à un léger autres centres si vous
voulez plus de conseils sur la
stimulation créativité et comment
booster un petit peu tout ça il ya un
super site qui existe qui s'appelle out
the box je vous mets le lien dans la
description
ceci n'est pas un placement de produit
puisque si c'en était un j'aurai
beaucoup d'argent et je n'aurais pas
fait vider aujourd'hui non mais c'est un
site que j'aime bien out the box point
fr c'est cool vous trouverez d'autres
trucs comme ça d'autres conseils et en
fait c'est stimulant de
hier des conseils sur la créativité
comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de
laisser un pouce en l'air avant de
quitter cette vidéo vous pouvez
également vous abonner en cliquant ici
et puis rendez vous très bientôt je
pense des bus semaine prochaine ciao
[Musique]